and we've been telling you about it for
a few weeks major construction on the
Las Vegas Strip and it's all
all ready for formula one which is
coming in November but some say these
delays are costing them repaving work is
happening on Las Vegas Boulevard and on
several other roads around it Sasha
Loftus joins us live tonight with more
on their frustrations a lot of people
are feeling behind the wheel Sasha
Denise and Brian of course another busy
night here on the Las Vegas Strip This
is where that Paving is happening you
can see behind me they're taking a night
off but all those cones are usually out
in the middle of the road causing major
delays for drivers now those we spoke
with say those delays are actually
causing them money
is very frustrating cones closures and
some serious congestion it was time
consuming you just sit and that's the
reality on the Las Vegas Strip as
Formula One race Paving continues
it's a pain for all of us but Uber and
Lyft drivers say it's also affecting
their bottom line it's hard to get
around so you lose money here's where
it's happening everything started on
sands Avenue with main work on the Las
Vegas Strip through May 19th then Harman
and Koval sing significant closures into
June
both rounds of track Paving and their
subsequent closures are set to wrap up
in mid-september you make a right turn
to try to deviate and go down the back
road that's blocked but Bridget Clayton
who's been driving Uber for years says
she's never seen it this bad and with
most surrounding roads ripped up it
feels like there's no way out I mean I
spent like 45 minutes in traffic
yesterday I'm trying to hit 20 rides I
can't most say they can't wait to see
what F1 brings to the valley
but as we all deal with these months of
preparation these drivers want to see
some relief on the horizon it's gonna
line up Pockets to some people some
people are going to lose weight
now the actual Formula One race is
happening the weekend of November 16th
right here on the Las Vegas Strip for a
closer look at that map of the closures
you saw and all those dates where roads
are affected we have a look at that on
our website 8newsnow.com reporting live
tonight Loftus 8 News Now